[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie pour
aujourd'hui j'ai le grand plaisir de
recevoir à nouveau genre de cortance qui
sort un livre sur Frida Kahlo intitulé
Viva Frida chez la tess Gérard de
cortance bonjour vous allez bien
on s'était vu au mois de mars pour
l'homme qui voulait voir la mer qui nous
a donné une image très étonnante de
notre bon vieux Louis XVI très étonnante
et très touchante c'est un livre qui
fait un carton d'ailleurs absolument
nombreux ouvrages en compte 90 livres à
votre actif
et vous avez écrit plusieurs livres sur
Frida Kahlo oui c'est trop tard
et alors d'où vient cette passion un
commenturable
poète à l'époque je pensais que je
n'écrirai jamais de roman donc je
n'écrivais que la poésie et j'avais pour
ami à Paris Carlos Fuentes et on faisait
partie de tout un groupe d'écrivains
c'est dans les années 70 il y avait
vargassiosa Julio corthasa Carlos
Fuentes et d'autres et ce sont eux qui
m'ont qui m'ont appris à écrire ces
caoutchent qui le premier m'a parlé de
Frida Kahlo évidemment tu ne connais pas
cette cette peintre mexicaine
extraordinaire ben non 17 ans dans la
France des années 70 Frida Kahlo on ne
connaissait pas tellement et vous savez
Wikipédia n'existait pas Google
n'hésitez pas les reproductions des
tableaux de Frida Kahlo n'en voyait pas
beaucoup la dernière exposition de Frida
Kahlo à Paris en France date de 1939
et la prochaine aura lieu en 92 à 82
dans les magasins au magasin du
printemps entre temps il y a rien eu
rien d'accord ok et donc une passion oui
oui alors là vraiment
oui
va être jeter nu dans la scène glacée
j'y serai allé c'était un peu comme un
comme un père comme un lieu vivant oui
bien sûr c'est un immense écrivain bon
bref vous avez quand même aimé de votre
immédiatement
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait j'ai toujours
été intéressé par par là les liens entre
l'écriture le
la création artistique et Freda Kahlo
oui c'est tout de suite je me suis dit
mais c'est c'est extraordinaire c'est
peintre enfin il faut qu'on en parle
absolument voilà exactement une oeuvre
une vie hallucinante alors alors
justement ce nouveau livre Viva Frida
qui est là vous dites ce n'est ni un
essai ni un roman ni une biographie
d'accord c'est les deux
et autre chose aussi c'est
des cours de mathématiques à l'école les
abscisses et les ordonnées et donc c'est
à dire c'est comme ça et comme ça donc
alors
sur la grandeur comme ça c'est la vie et
vous avez des thématiques alors par
exemple vous avez la religion le sang la
mexicanité la révolution mexicaine etc
donc je raconte la vie de fruits
d'akallo et je dégage des thématiques
tout au long de sa vie puisque vous
savez très bien elle elle l'a dit
elle-même elle ne peint que ce qu'elle
vit elle ne peint pas ses rêves elle ne
peut pas passer songe elle ne peint que
ce qu'il vit et alors il y a deux
blessures principales chez Frida Kahlo
il y a les blessures physiques qui sont
liées on en parlera sans doute la
maladie l'hôpital etc et d'autres
blessures qui sont les blessures à
penser morales qui sont liés à la vie
avec des Gori vera
l'adultère enfin les choses comme ça qui
la blessent donc il y a ces deux ces
deux fractures et qui apparaissent
toujours dans ces tableaux d'accord et
moi j'ai l'impression que votre livre il
a une construction assez particulière
c'est à dire que quand vous dites il y a
pas vraiment de chronologie dans chaque
chapitre chaque chapitre a pour titre
une citation de Frida Kahlo voilà c'est
bien je me suis beaucoup appuyé
suivez-moi sur sur ses écrits choses
qu'on ne fait jamais parce que il y a
beaucoup écrit c'est-à-dire le son
journal
les textes et l'écrit sur ces tableaux
et puis toute la correspondance qui est
extraordinaire alors je termine juste
sur le coup des chapitres
on a l'impression que chaque chapitre a
émis ce suffit à lui-même
comme un mini histoire vous voyez ce que
je veux dire
pas de chronologie
la seule chronologie c'est la vie que je
suis de la naissance à la mort à
l'intérieur de cette thématique c'est
une sorte de puzzle quoi on peut revenir
à un événement passé
dans le livre c'est de ne pas être
répétitif parce que un même tableau peut
apparaître à différents endroits puisque
c'est lié à la thématique mais j'ai
vraiment tant que faire ce pneu essayez
de ne jamais jamais répéter les choses
et je pense que je suis perdu c'est à
dire que à chaque fois le tableau est
cité mais je n'analyse qu'un élément du
tableau par exemple si je prends un
tableau qui s'appelle le quelques
petites piqûres c'est un tableau très
très célèbre où on la voit on voit une
femme nue sur un lit qui est leur dit
coup de couteau elle baigne dans dans
son sang et il y a un homme qui est
debout à côté d'elle avec
une main dans sa poche et l'autre qui
tient un couteau et ben en fait vous le
tableau peut être analysé différents
moments du livre il peut analyser dans
la thématique autour du sang il peut
être analysé dans la thématique
Diego me trompe et d'ailleurs je peins
ce tableau lorsque Diego m'a trompé avec
telle ou telle femme c'est à la suite de
ça que j'écris ce tableau que je pense
ce tableau parce que j'éprouve une
douleur et ça voilà et ça c'est le
cheminement alors comment dire
profond de Frida Kahlo et qui est
vraiment une une clé de voût du lit
c'est à dire c'est quelqu'un qui va
transformer ces douleurs en création
artistique ce qui n'est pas toujours le
cas vous savez moi je suis éditeur et
parfois je reçois des manuscrits qu'ils
sont qui sont de très mauvais livres
mais à l'origine il y a une douleur
c'est quelqu'un qui a perdu telle ou
telle membre de sa famille qui a vécu
tel était le moment difficile mais qu'il
n'arrive qu'il ne parvient pas à
transformer
cette douleur en création artistique or
le ce qui est très très fort et très
puissant je te fais des cadeaux et je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'on l'aime
c'est à dire on voit tout à fait donc
chaque tableau le cheminement de la
douleur à la création elle arrive à
transformer sa douleur en
œuvre d'art vous savez il y a une phrase
de il y a une phrase de Proust qui est
très importante il dit au fond ce qui
m'intéresse oui ils disent qu'il
m'intéresse c'est pas la douleur c'est
l'originalité de ma douleur c'est ce que
ma douleur a de personnes d'originalité
elle m'appartient ma douleur et donc je
vais la transformer en
œuvre voilà exactement et ça c'est c'est
c'est ce que j'ai voulu indiquer dans
dans dans ce livre donc pour revenir
juste deux secondes sur vos sources donc
elle écrivait un journal c'est cela
c'est correspondances il y a aussi des
témoignages de sa nièce la fille de sa
sœur isolement et les témoignages sont
essentiels par exemple on parle beaucoup
de la clodication de Frida
kahloïde à 6 ans pour commencer dans les
réjouissances je trouve que cet
événement est aussi important que le
l'accident dont parle-moi on nous rebat
les oreilles toujours c'est soit
excitant bien mais il y a la polio avant
et la polio c'était essentiel parce que
à partir de là elle a eu un regard un
certain regard sur la vie sur
l'existence et c'est peut-être aussi
important que l'accident qui qui va
suivre oui parce que c'est cette maladie
dont elle connaît la souffrance elle
connaît les moqueries voilà et et j'ai
l'impression qu'à partir de ce moment là
sa vie n'est que lutte
lutter contre donc les moqueries et puis
il y a un exemple assez rigolo que vous
donnez elle demande à Noël un avion
mécanique elle est petite qu'est-ce
qu'on lui offre un déguisement d'ange et
sa mère dit elle est bien assez garçon
manqué comme ça ça veut dire qu'il va
encore falloir lutter pour avoir ce
qu'on veut à Noël quoi malgré déjà oui
elle est dans la lune
ce que je n'ai pas voulu faire non plus
c'est à dire en faire comme on va dire
une féministe à tout cruin c'est pas ça
c'est-à-dire je vais essayer de la
replacer dans le contexte de l'époque
alors le contexte de l'époque on est
dans les années 20 les années 30 au
Mexique donc c'est une femme mexicaine
la femme mexicaine dans la société
mexicaine de l'époque n'a pas beaucoup
de place bien que la révolution soit là
et que l'émancipation de la femme
devrait arriver avec mais elle n'arrive
pas tellement et Frida Kahlo se bat pour
cela mais comment dire c'est
c'est pratiquement inconscient c'est à
dire elle est comme ça elle a passé sa
vie à se battre elle est dans la lutte
en permanente elle est dans la lutte
quand elle rencontre Diego et dans la
lutte contre quand elle veut comment
dire qu'on expose sa peinture quand il
faut qu'elle vende une peinture qui est
pas une peinture agréable imaginez la
bourgeoisie mexicaine de l'époque que
voulez-vous qu'elle fasse de de des
tableaux de féda Kahlo ce ne sont pas
des tableaux ce sont pas des tableaux
qu'on met dans son comme décoration dans
son dans son salon ce sont pas des
tableaux agréables ce sont des des des
tableaux qui racontent une vie violente
cassée fracassée la douleur et notamment
tout ce qui tourne autour de la femme et
je pense que c'est pour ça qu'elle elle
traverse le temps comme ça et qu'elle
elle est si moderne fait d'accord pour
les femmes oui alors je dis que c'est un
c'est une femme qui peint pour les
femmes
mais je souhaite que tous les hommes
aillent voir ses étoiles d'accord et
alors
elle dit je serai l'ami de ceux qui
m'aiment tel que je suis en fait elle
lutte pas pour lutter elle lutte pour
être elle-même et être acceptée telle
qu'elle est point sans aller brosser les
gens dans le sens du poil et ça n'en a
que faire alors un moment elle vient à
Paris et elle rencontre les surréalistes
et je peux pas hésiter l'envie de vous
citer elle dit on est en 39 je crois
voilà elle dit
elle dit on envahi par cette bande de
fils de lunatique que sont les
surréalistes n'aiment pas beaucoup André
Breton
mais il a le malheur de lui expliquer ce
que c'est que le surréalisme de de dans
sa grandement souhaitudes de bien
vouloir l'accueillir dans le grand
mouvement surréaliste et elle lui dit
écoutez André au Mexique on n'a pas
attendu on vous a pas attendu pour être
surréaliste alors pour se venger parce
que elle a elle est pleine du mot aussi
donc pour se venger elle va coucher avec
la femme de Breton voilà parce qu'elle
est comme vous dites pansexuelle
exactement
là aussi c'est très intéressant parce
que les elle était sortie de l'oubli
dans les années 70 fin des années 70 par
lesbiennes américaines d'accord alors on
les remercie parce que c'est vrai
qu'elles ont eu un rôle très important
dans la redécouverte de Fresnes
non mais elle n'était pas lesbienne du
tout c'est à dire elle aimait autant les
hommes que les femmes alors et
aujourd'hui alors on en fait quelqu'un
qui aurait un genre fluide transgen etc
c'est à dire que c'est très étonnant
parce qu'en fonction des époques on
arrive toujours à la placer dans une
dans une case mais je pense que ces
cases sont fausses d'accord c'est à dire
elle était elle-même elle a pas besoin
qu'on la met dans une gaz elle est
complètement inclassable et un casable
et c'est ce qui fait la force elle
voulait rentrer dans rien exactement et
même
elle est inclassable Frida Kahlo mais
son rapport au surréaliste ce qu'elle
leur reproche parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que Frédéric calots elle est
issue de la Révolution Mexicaine
c'est à dire avec c'est quand le peuple
le Mexicain retrouve son passé mexicain
et se détache de l'Europe et bien ce
qu'elle reproche au surréaliste au fond
c'est de faire la révolution de prôner
la révolution qu'ils le feront jamais et
c'est bien vous savez qu'au Mexique on
dit au fond c'est nous qui avons inventé
la révolution c'est pas les Russes avec
la révolution de 17 révolution mexicaine
elle a lieu 7 ans avant 1910 d'accord et
alors vu que le temps passe est-ce que
vous pouvez me dire en deux mots ce que
c'est qu'une nature vivent oui
des autoportraits parce que cloué au lit
avec un miroir un chevalet spécial elle
peint ce qu'elle vit qu'est-ce qu'elle
vit sa douleur et qu'est-ce qu'elle voit
son visage donc énormément
d'autoportrait et aussi des natures
vives ça veut dire quoi une nature
vivent alors juste une elle n'a pas
peint toute son œuvre sur un fauteuil
roulant ou allongé c'est la légende
j'essaie de dire le contraire
mais en revanche c'est vrai qu'elle a
transformé le mot nature morte en
naturevie c'est-à-dire que c'est c'était
elle peignait des fruits des légumes
mettez au milieu des petits drapeaux
mexicains c'est-à-dire c'était des
tapots des tableaux nationalistes
le peignait le Mexique puisque les
fruits et les légumes des dégoût des
fruits et des légumes mexicains et ce
sont aussi des autoportraits puisqu'elle
dit il y a certains tableaux c'est moi
parce que comme je suis parfois
tellement malade ou je sors de l'hôpital
j'ai l'impression d'être un légume donc
littéralement elle va peindre un légume
parce que c'est elle toute façon elle
n'a pas finalement il y a 70
autoportraits 75 sur une œuvre picturale
qui comporte environ 130 toiles mais
on peut dire que la presque totalité de
son œuvre ce sont des autoportraits elle
est toujours dans des tableaux d'accord
et le dernier tableau paraît-il qu'elle
est pain avant de mourir peut-être en se
donnant la mort on sait pas ce serait
vivant la vida oui alors c'est un livre
qui essaie de de d'être un peu à
contre-courant de tous les clichés
autour de Frida Kahlo alors par exemple
non elle n'a pas claudiqué toute sa vie
non elle n'est pas née à la Casa soul
mais plus loin etc etc et non le dernier
tableau n'est pas Viva la Vida ça alors
ça arrange tout le monde parce que
c'est des pastèques
c'est magnifique c'est un cliché c'est
c'est comme les taïwana c'est c'est
robes dont on fait maintenant des
modèles de mode or c'était quand elle
porte elle était wanna c'était sablière
je suis mexicaine j'ai fait la
révolution mexicaine bien
donc pour répondre à votre question son
dernier tableau non c'est une c'est un
portrait de Staline bien mais alors ça
c'est très gênant parce qu'évidemment
elle a été la menthe de Trotski oui mais
elle était tellement de ski là encore
parce que c'était une petite coquine
pour emmerder il y a pas d'autres termes
son mari Diego Riverdale mais tout
simplement parce que elle faisait
tellement elle a fait l'amour avec
d'abord celui qui a couché avec sa sœur
Christine Christina avec des mots et
avec le père avec le père de la
Quatrième Internationale et ça c'est le
musée beaucoup parce que Diego était
comme à dire un communiste dogmatique
bien le communisme de Frida Kahlo et
comment dire c'est pas quelqu'un de
dogmatique c'est quelqu'un qui est il y
a une empathie profonde pour les pour
les gens pour les exclus pour pour les
gens pour les 100 grades etc et son
dernier tableau c'est une ode à Staline
c'est pas un c'est pas un geste
politique dogmatique je comprends mais
c'est très embêtant évidemment ça fait
un peu tâche quoi c'est à dire ah bah
oui la petite Frida Kahlo dont on voit
partout dont on en fait des montres on
en fait des poupées Barbie et bien c'est
peut-être une communiste et elle a peint
elle a pas une un tableau de Staline qui
est à la cassation qu'on peut voir qui
est inachevé parce que c'est son dernier
tableau mais c'est moins glamour que
vivent à la vida bon bref voilà la
vérité rétablit alors Gérard de Corton
c'est un grand merci pour ce livre
formidable vous allez en écrire encore
un ou sur Frida Kahlo parce que c'est le
dernier oui il est possible que je n'ai
écrit un autre c'est vrai
et bien un grand merci donc j'encourage
tout le monde à dévorer ce livre qui est
fourmillant foisonnant et incroyable
comme comme la vie de cette femme hors
du commun voilà au revoir à tous merci
de nous avoir suivi à bientôt pour un
nouveau VIP
[Musique]